[Música]
vistas desde el cielo o debajo del agua
son igual de impresionantes las maldivas
200 islas regadas por uno de los
arrecifes de coral más grandes del mundo
con una extensión de más de 2000
kilómetros son el hogar de incontables
especies marinas
pero están en peligro
aquí
este es hassan ahmed un fanático del
buceo originario de las maldivas que en
los últimos años ha visto morir más de
la mitad de los corales que rodean la
isla donde vive
y la manera de saber que un coral ha
muerto es porque no tiene color todavía
al acercarse no se ven colores ni vida
animal
encima y parece una piedra
en esta parcela del arrecife el panorama
es alarmante los corales vivos han
desaparecido y el suelo marino está
cubierto de arena y rocas la
construcción alrededor del atolón y el
aumento de la temperatura del agua son
algunas de las causas de este desastre
ecológico en 2016 el fenómeno climático
del niño tuvo un efecto devastador en la
región
la temperatura del agua estaba superando
los niveles en los que pueden sobrevivir
los corales los corales se blanquearon
por el color del agua
ese año el 60% de los arrecifes de coral
de la isla fueron afectados por el niño
y como se trata de un fenómeno climático
recurrente hassan ahmed se está
preparando para el próximo puede pasarme
esa herramienta junto con otros miembros
de la organización que fundó está
tratando de encontrar una nueva manera
de proteger los arrecifes de coral mega
trozos de coral sanó a estos ladrillos y
espera que así crezca una nueva colonia
una especie dejamos un poco de espacio
aquí así que cuando empiecen a crecer
esperamos que se fusionen y cuando todos
hayan crecido será un solo gran coral
si funciona hassan ahmed piensa replicar
el método para volver a llenar de vida
las aguas que rodean las maldivas
[Música]
a unos cuantos kilómetros otro método ya
está dando resultado
[Música]
américa es una bióloga marina originaria
de bayona trabaja para una fundación de
la isla y es la encargada de un programa
de reproducción de arrecifes de coral
para alguien de mi profesión las
maldivas es uno de los mejores países
del mundo es un lugar único con una vida
marina única el año pasado a mel instaló
200 estructuras de metal a las que se
ataron distintas especies de corales
desde entonces han crecido y se han
desarrollado
atrayendo nueva vida marina
todo el coral que sembramos está muy
bien hemos visto que ha crecido y están
llegando pues a la zona efe - taiwán a
pax ha tenido un impacto muy positivo
las maldivas tienen alrededor de 250
especies distintas de corales son anna
simó cree que todo el mundo debería
participar en su producción estamos
listos para la sesión de hoy fue la
primera mujer en las maldivas en obtener
un certificado de buceo ahora imparte
clases gratuitas a los niños para
enseñarles por qué es importante
proteger los arrecifes de coral
no se puede proteger algo que no se ama
hay que enamorarse del arrecife y del
océano sólo así es posible esforzarse
por preservar los elementos
en el agua a su nana sin lleva a los
niños a una zona donde el arrecife está
afectado para que puedan ser testigos
del desastre actual
like
es como si los pescados estuvieran
perdiendo su hogar y si hay menos peces
el océano no será tan hermoso es muy
triste que estemos perdiendo los corales
el aspecto ambiental es tan solo una
cara de la crisis la preservación de los
arrecifes de coral es clave para la
supervivencia de las maldivas con 80%
del archipiélago a menos de un metro por
encima del nivel del mar los arrecifes
juegan un papel vital para protegerlo
del aumento del nivel de las aguas